hello everyone and welcome to another
very interesting clash from yesterday's
melt weather champions chester finals
it's wesley saw versus hikaru nakamura
and this is already the blitz section so
the four rapid games they played ended
in extremely quick draws there were like
very few moves in the opening and then
they just drew the game
very well known drawing lines i guess
neither of them was interested in trying
out anything new in the rapid because
why would they and a lot of people are
saying that that's no way to treat chess
that's no way to play but to the
uh the reality is that the players
simply have uh too much on their plate
nowadays you finish one tournament you
have like uh one day to rest and you
have to prepare for a new tournament
that features many new players that have
different rapper repertoires
and you you really can't uh you know uh
constantly keep up with with the demand
of
honing in your skills in new openings so
that's why i think it's not that weird
that players would just um say okay
we're not going to play the four rapid
games let's just uh ended this uh in a
blitz tie break uh imagine if you had 20
games and then if the 20 games ended in
a draw you would have two two blitz
tiebreaks of course some players would
also do that and go straight into the
blitz tie breaks uh so in the first uh
blitz tiebreak where hikaru had the
white pieces he carou won and now this
is the second game or game six of their
match wesley has the white pieces he
needs to win at the force armageddon now
it's a blitz game uh so keep that in
mind a lot of ideas were missed here but
that's why we enjoy blitz uh some would
say that uh you know not some but uh
that analyzing blitz is stupid but uh
you know it's the positions that we're
interested in uh so that's uh that's why
we do it uh so let's check it out it's
quite the game wesley with the white
pieces opens with e4
we have e5 by hikaru knight to f3 knight
to c6 and now d4 going for the scotch uh
e capture sunday for knight captures and
knight to f6 and now yeah wesley goes
for the very well known mises variation
knight captures e captures sorry not d
captures b captures uh and e5 now we are
in the mises variation of the scotch uh
queen to e7 now pinning the pawn so you
can't really capture the knight and the
white defends the pawn with queen to e2
interposing and now ready to capture the
knight on f6 we have knights to d5 uh
and here usually what players go for is
just c4 knight b6 let's say b3 develop
the bishop on this long diagonal
that's how this is uh usually played i
think wesley even played this in 2016
against gary caspar although wesley i
believe had the black pieces
that gary won but i think also wesley
won one game in this line
but here uh wesley goes for h4 and this
is 2021 h4 can be played in any move in
any position of any opening that's just
how chess works nowadays uh it's been
played before so hikaru goes for a5 uh
he wants to play bishop to a6 to put a
lot of pressure on the on the white
queen and now c4 chasing the knight away
and now uh not really worrying about
bishop to a6 you could play bishop to a6
right away then the knight can remain on
d5 for the moment uh but uh this didn't
really give black all that much in in
the games that it was played so here
knight back to b6 uh now we're gonna try
and put more pressure on this c4 pawn
knight to d2 and now there are some
games where queen the e6 were was played
also a4 is a known move but he car
replaced g6 and it is now as of move 10
that we have a completely new game so
wesley continues with h5 if this bishop
is fiance to g7 maybe you can further
harass it with h6 uh but not right away
yeah so hikaru goes for bishop to g7
there's uh the problem of the e5 pawn
hanging so you have to defend that and
wesley has to decide how to do it he
could play something like f4 but then
the king side is wide open the queen
side is wide open
where are you castling with your king
now this can be played but the wesley
decides to go for a more adventurous
idea knight to f3 and now hikaru says
all right if you don't want to castle
you you're definitely not castling he
plays queen to be for with check and now
the problem is if bishop to d2 we're
going to capture on b2 and this is now a
completely crazy uh position that uh
it's not bad for white white can't
sacrifice this pawn for for activity
but if you don't have this prepared
maybe going for this in a blitz game
against hikaru who is a very very fast
and very very good chess player uh
maybe maybe not the greatest of ideas so
wesley just plays king to d1 and now he
carl goes for bishop to a6 now attacking
this c pawn three times but it's not a
problem just b3 and we really don't care
it seems like black is really going
after white but
if you look at it the bishop and knight
here are never entering the game so
we're not really worried about that the
bishop is
also
just attacking that e5 pawn nothing
really happening there so the only
attacker hikaru has for the moment is
this queen on b4 and that's nothing to
worry about so here we have castle's
queen side uh also very adventurous
castle in king's side would be a bit
safer but hikar wants to open up the
position here as wesley's king is still
in the center of the board so h6 we want
to disconnect hikaru's rooks bishop to
f8 and now knight the g5 going after
this f7 pawn like i said this is a blitz
game so of course you can't
find everything over the board but i
will just show one line that's
incredibly pleasant and that is queen to
d3 now this is uh really weird to play
if black has a rook here he's ready to
open up the d file you do not want your
queen and king occupying the d file but
here
it just works because if d6 here now we
play a3 and we trap black's queen so
that's very unfortunate queen to c5
bishop e3 and the queen is lost of
course we we also have to give up our
own queen but we're gonna grab the
exchange for example d captures on e5
we're gonna grab the rook with chuck
king captures and now we're gonna
capture black queen and see five bishop
captures and now let's say knight
captures an e5 we want material uh we we
feel great we're attacking f7 we're
gonna win more material or c6 we're
gonna win that so white is just much
better here and still this bishop and
knight really don't have a way of
entering the game uh
in any reasonable way okay you can play
knight to d7 then but but for the bishop
it's going to be a bit harder you still
need a a few moves so instead after
bishop to f8 we have knight to g5 uh and
now uh the f7 pawn is hanging queen to
a7 by hikaru and now rook the h3 now
wesley has uh more uh pressure here
along the third rank and uh well it's
just a very useful move we have d5 by
hikaru not going for d6 if you go for d6
right away then we can capture this and
as the queens are staring at each other
it's not really a problem if queen
captures on d6 now we're just gonna move
the king and we don't really care the
bishop is coming to b2 rook is coming to
d1 this rook is coming to d3 white is
perfectly fine here so he car played the
d5 uh and now e captures on d6 alpha
song now you could capture with the rook
but like we said kink the c2 and the
white is perfectly fine here so queen to
d7 hikaru doesn't want to trade queens
the white king is still in the center of
the board so we want to keep as many
attacking opportunities alive as
possible and king to c2 now we have
bishop captures on d6 by hikaru and now
rook to d3 uh now the bishop cannot move
we have rook h to e8 attacking wesley's
queen and queen to f3 now uh and here uh
the f7 pawn is attacked twice so he car
plays f5 now uh
this threat is gone and also the queen
now guards the h7 pawn it would be uh
extremely dangerous if he carol allowed
this knight to capture this then wastely
gets a beautiful pass pawn here and the
game would probably be over very quickly
and now wesley plays bishop to e3 uh you
could also play bishop to b2 as planned
and bring the other rook to d1 but
wesley plays bishop to e3 instead
with the ideas of maybe pushing this c5
pawn at some point for the moment it's
not possible the bishop is still kind of
useful here on a6 but here wesley missed
pretty much a winning move uh that is
bishop to f4
it's not clear right away why it's
winning uh it just is what what do you
play here for black there doesn't seem
to be a move that black can play uh to
give you an example if you try something
like c5 and uh well kind of makes sense
you want to bring the bishop over here
we are gonna play rook a to d1 now put
even more pressure on the bishop here
and if bishop to b7 attacking the queen
we're going to play queen to g3
and now the pressure on d6 is just
unbearable so this is one way to go
about it another way to tackle bishop to
f4 is go for the tricky knight to d5
line like we said if the pawn captures
the rook falls with check uh but you
don't really care about this we're still
gonna capture the knight and then after
bishop captures on it for queen captures
now we capture the rook with check
bishop captures queen captures on d5 but
now rook a to d1 and it's a pretty crazy
position but it uh it is better for
white there's really no no
way for for black to force anything you
still have the weak pawn here black's
king is weak
and it's just uh just a better position
for for white however this is a blitz
game let's not forget that wesley played
bishop to e3 and now he car replaced c5
just uh
trying to prevent an any c5 future from
white uh moves uh from white in the
future and preparing bishop to be seven
uh and now he uh wesley played bishop to
e2 and this is uh not the the way to go
about it you could also uh maybe play
bishop captures on c5 uh but then bishop
to b7 and it's still
very very unclear as to what what is
happening here but okay after c5 whistle
played bishop to e2 and now hikaru plays
queen to e7 here hikaru has the upper
hand and bishop to b7 is actually deadly
but uh what do you do here after queen
to h3 there's this incredible line of
knight captures on c4 and after b
captures if you don't capture i mean you
just uh you just have a worse position
but to give you an idea of what is
happening we're going to deliver queen
tape for check go after this spawn and
after rook to b3 we can even play bishop
to f4 and black is completely dominating
the position if the bishop captures then
this bishop falls away to check we're
threatening queen captures here bishop
is also coming to e4 uh but even if
something like bishop to f1 we can still
just play rook captures on e3 we remove
the defender of the knight here and once
the pawn is captured we pick up the the
knight here and there's really no good
way to continue this with white if
bishop to d3 we still play bishop to e4
we don't care if if bishop captures
we're going to capture with the queen
king b2 queen captures here and now it's
just completely completely winning for
for black too many uh ideas here uh but
okay uh here hikaru played queen to e7
and now comes queen to h3 stopping this
pawn from advancing to f4 the king is on
c8 so hikaru of course moves it king to
b8 and now g3 by wesley uh this was uh
probably the the moment where f4 has to
be played but it's such an ugly move you
you like your bishop here defended by
the f2 pawn you do not want to have your
queen and rook defending this bishop and
of course the bishop still can't move
because this bishop is hanging here but
wesley played the g3
kind of stopping f4 but now bishop the
c8 he carl prepares f4 because now f4
comes with an attack on the bishop and
the queen uh and now last moment for
wesley uh to play this f4 move the rook
still guards the bishop so white could
still hang on here but he played queen
to h1
and now of course the position is
completely winning for hikaru but you
still have to be very careful so feel
free to pause the video and win this
game ended the match for kikaru while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on paying attention
but also you know chipping in a little
bit more and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
f4 that's the good stuff this is what
hikaru played uh g captures on f4 was
played bishop captures on f4 and it was
in this position unmoved 27
that wesley so resigned to the game and
with it the match uh so why why does he
resign here uh it doesn't really matter
what you do the game is just lost
because there are there's too many
threats here like bishop to f5 would go
after the rook we can just win a piece
here with bishop captures queen captures
so there's nothing to try here if you
try queen h4 to bring a defender here uh
we're still going to capture it bishop
captures queen captures and now after we
trade the bishop on e2 is still hanging
so rook characters on e2 and you're just
dead lost
and on the other hand after bishop
captures on f4 uh you might try let's
say rook captures on the e8 but it still
doesn't matter queen captures on the
eight we're still threatening to pick up
the knight and if knight to f3 uh let's
say then we go for bishop to f5 check uh
and now there are too many uh squares
not available to this white king you
could move it king b2 now we're just
going to play bishop captures on h6 and
we're completely winning whatever you
play let's say queen captures an h6
because why not just queen to f6 with
check and you are uh losing uh a lot
regardless of what you play once the
king moves we're gonna lose the rook
here and that's just uh that that's just
game
uh so yeah after bishop captures on f4
uh wesley resigned and an excellent
victory for hikaru in the blitz section
of the of the round four of the
milwaukee champions chester finals so
the there's a plus side to you know
skipping the rapids and going straight
for the blitz section but there's also
the the downside the downside being
obviously that if you lose uh you you
just lost and you don't have as many
chances to come back as you would have
in the rapid
time section
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it thank you for suggesting
this one uh i would like to thank
hashgamer uh david kimura myself for
making great videos guadalajara and
keegan burmark up realty for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
fine event uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day